Here's nearly the same exact problem except this time we have a less than
symbol. I'm going to solve this inequality just like before. First, 2x plus 1
can be less than 7 here or 2x plus 1 could be greater than negative 7 here. But
I don't have to solve these separately. I know 2x plus 1 is less than 7, but
greater than negative 7. So it's in between these 2 numbers. Let's just write 1
inequality and solve it. First I can subtract 1 from all 3 parts. This gives me
negative 8 is less than 2 x is less than 6. Now I just divide every part by 2.
So x is greater than negative 4 but less than 3. It's between these values. We
can see we get the numbers between negative 4 and 3. Using parentheses we can
include these point because we don't have an equal to by here. This would be the
answer in interval notation. In the last problem we had a greater than symbol
and we got the outside portions of the number line. For the less than symbol, we
get an intersection, the part in between. I hope this helps with your problem
solving.